in the meantime we're also talking about
the parade that starts a few hours from
right now uh some of the side streets
are already closed around 4th street the
parade going from gas up to stuart we'll
have a live report from bianca coming up
in just a few minutes john heather and
he will do that right now nate at 603
today we are honoring the life of dr
martin luther king jr the parade today
to recognize his fight for civil rights
you know it's been a tradition here for
the past 40 years a big event one to
definitely go to if you have the day off
the theme of this year living the dream
setting new standards and bianca holman
joining us live downtown to talk more
about the parade hi bianca good morning
good morning so this parade is one of
the largest in the state and again it's
become a tradition like you shared so
the parade will become right along here
down along 4th street and it will start
here at 4th and gas avenue which will be
the start of the parade and the north
las vegas police department honor guard
they've been selected to lead the annual
martin luther king junior day parade
this morning so this is the 40th year
for the parade here in the city serving
as the grand marshal this year is
juwanna malone aka the tech queen
she's the executive director of the
nevada help desk and then there is also
shondell
newsom he's also a grand marshal he is a
marketing expert helping small
businesses reach their full potential
and while this may be a day off for many
las vegas leaders want people to take
the time to reflect on the journey of
racial equality here in america and also
in the valley
they are recognized in the take note of
all those ambassadors that fought for us
that bled for us that died for us in
order to be here and to have the
freedoms that we have today
it's not just only about the celebration
of dr martin luther king in this day but
it's about all the other
people that have worked alongside him
who led that charge to get us where we
are today
all right so here's the rundown for the
parade it will be along 4th street
as a result of road closures in the area
those are going to start around 6 a.m to
4 p.m and the following roads will be
closed fourth street from charleston
boulevard to stewart avenue and all the
side streets in between and remember
staging is going to be on coolidge
hoover and gas avenue from casino center
to las vegas boulevard so the parade
starts at 10 a.m again all those things
will be starting to happen around 8 a.m
for those that are coming to the parade
you'll want to get here early stake out
a spot and coming up in the next half
hour we're going to share a couple of
more events that are happening this week
in honor of mlk day today bianca holman
live local now